a game-changing donation and listen to
those words
game-changing donation to help
struggling students and you're hearing
about it first on cbs mornings we love
when that happens mackenzie scott has
given away billions since 2020 following
her divorce from amazon founder jeff
bezos and now she's donating here's the
drum roll please
133 and a half million dollars to the
non-profit communities and schools also
known as cis the organization helps more
than a million students nationwide
navigate issues inside and outside the
classroom giving them access to things
like food housing health care and
technology
ray saldana is cis president and ceo
he's also an alum of the program so he
knows what this is all about here's a
very dramatic moment that he revealed
the donation to the group's founder
instead of
saying it out loud i might share it and
let you see it for the first time
[Music]
what's the total that's the total
other one did she ever know about us
holy mackerel
should i
say it and i loved it
you could say it because it's hard to
say sometimes
it's 133.
[Music]
wow i love a holy mackerel moment don't
you ray saldana good morning to you
but you're the one ray who got that
initial call so set the scene you're in
a hotel you're at home you're in the
classroom what happened yeah
i was in a hotel room and you know as a
head of a non-profit you're always just
thinking about the work you're thinking
about the people you're thinking about
the impact
and this call came out of nowhere and
they described what was this news that
the head of a nonprofit you're just it's
a once in a lifetime opportunity because
you think about all of the work that you
can do what did they say what did they
say uh well they described that they
were going to be making an unrestricted
gift to our organization and they were
going to make a gift to our office and
also directly to the affiliates where
the work is happening every single day
what did you think unrestrictive meant
well
in our world it's rare uh oftentimes
when we get a gift it's prescribed but
in this case it meant that you've got
the flexibility and they had trust in us
and wow and she is so you know i know
but how much did you think it meant you
couldn't have thought it was 133 million
that's what i mean the upper limits of
my imagination were we would be lucky if
we get a 10 million dollar gift and
that's that's what i'd expected and
hopefully that's what i might hear why
do you think you were picked your
organization you know um we will never
know and the the team was really good
about saying that what they do is a ton
of research on your organization so we
were taking a test we didn't know we
were we passed the test we didn't know
we were taking we're taking yeah now now
when you work in a non-profit and with a
non-profit there's long days short
mornings um you're oftentimes very
exhausted you work in faith because you
don't see the end result
what does this say about the people
behind this nonprofit oh gosh you know i
think about this from a very personal
perspective because our work really is
about placing a trusting adult in a
school to interact and i had a cis staff
member when i was going through really
so i think about
the 3 000 staff that we have inside
schools working along alongside our
principals and teachers the hope that
they now have as they think about
expanding to touch more lives and impact
more students it's just incredible
because that's not something you expect
you try to reach your ambition and your
mission and we want to get into every
title one school that is serving
students of low income and that's me
that's my neighbors that's my community
and to think about how difficult the
last two years have been really puts in
place the gift and how this is going to
accelerate our growth personally what
did it do for you ray yeah so i i met
communities in schools when i met mrs
reyes and we have staff who was trained
to go into schools where you work with
students and they not only build a
relationship with you they work on
addressing social and emotional needs
and removing barriers and as a first
generation american first in my family
to graduate and go to college it was
again my the upper limits of my ambition
were you know sometimes around my
environment so i really expanded the
universe for me and so as i think about
how we can do that for more students
especially around how we're suffering so
much through the emotional trauma of
covid this is what we need inside our
schools when you talk about removing
barriers what kind of barriers are being
brushed aside because of donations like
this oh what this allows us to do is to
really as our name says bring a
community of support inside our schools
to empower students to not just graduate
from school but achieve in life and so
some of those barriers for students who
have lost a caretaker who's whose family
member may have lost a job creating
instability
those are problems that sometimes
surface in schools in outbursts or
students who have their heads down
living just below the surface those are
those conflicts that if we don't address
the you know students can't get turned
on to learning unless they're turned on
to living and the living is the hard
part and that's what we are there
everything from food shelter to clothing
and mental health services that's what's
needed to get these students turned on
to learning yeah have you talked to
mackenzie scott no i haven't haven't
talked to her what would you say to her
yes oh my gosh the the amount of
gratitude um in my language muchisimas
gracias for what this is going to do for
the ambitions of our organization to
think about you know we have this
twinkle in our eye about growing into
every title one school yeah we're in 3
000 schools today this helps us really
drive and because so much has so much
pressure has come down because of
pandemic we can now bring more staff
into the schools that we're in already
and this is amazing i hope you get a
chance to meet her i've met her she's
lovely please tell her she has a seat at
the table right where you're sitting
whenever she wants because the work
she's doing is amazing yeah you guys are
doing this amazing yeah and as you know
the work is just beginning yes
thank you so much for joining us